يدعي بوتين النصر ، ويقول الأوكرانيون
إن المدينة لم تسقط بعد ، لكن ماريو
بول في الغالب يسيطر على
الكولونيل الروس بينما نبدأ في النظر في
حصار ماريو بول ، ما يجعل هذه
المدينة الساحلية بالغة الأهمية لفلاديمير بوتين بريان ،
ما هو الأمر الحاسم في هذا الأمر.  يصنع
الجزء الأخير من الجسر البري
الذي أراده الروس من شبه جزيرة القرم
وصولًا إلى دونباس ثم
إلى روسيا أخيرًا ، لذلك عندما يكون لديهم هذا
الجسر البري الذي يعمل على إخراج هذا الجزء
من الساحل من الطاولة
لأوكرانيا ويحتمل أن يضع  في لعب الجزء الغربي
هنا ، إذا قاموا بالدوران والتحرك
نحو أوديسا ، فلنلقِ نظرة الآن
على ما يُسمى ألامو
ماريو بول وهذه هي المعركة من أجل
هذا المجمع ، كما هو الحال في
نواة مجمع الحديد والصلب ، فإنها تأخذ
أربعة مربعات  أميال من القطب ماريو الجنوبي ،
إنه مجمع مترامي الأطراف من
مباني المستودعات ، مسارات السكك الحديدية ، أكوام الدخان ،
الطرق ، لديه ميناء خاص به ولكنه يحتوي
أيضًا على شبكة تحت الأرض  k من
أنفاق الغرف وأنظمة الاتصالات ونحن
ننظر إلى هذا الفيديو الذي نحصل
عليه قبل وبعد الفيديو قبل
الفيديو من نيويورك تايمز
وقبل الحصار هذا بعد الفيديو
ما هي هذه الميزات التي تحدثت
عنها مما يجعلها  من الصعب جدًا
أن يتم التقاط هذا المجمع من قبل
الروس ، لذا فإن بريان هو الأمر
الصعب حقًا بشأن هذا هو الطبيعة الكهفية
لهذا التفكير ستالينجراد في
الحرب العالمية الثانية ، حيث تنظر إلى أنواع
المباني التي لديك هنا
وترى بالضبط مدى صعوبة ذلك
تخيل نفسك تقاتل من خلال
هذا وتحاول العثور على غرفة يمكنك
تنظيفها وعليك أن تفعل ذلك
مئات المرات آلاف المرات في جميع أنحاء
هذا المجمع
، سيكون من
الصعب للغاية التقاطك ترى كل هذه
الصخور هنا وإذا كان الروس  القوات
لا تفهم أين توجد بعض
هذه الأماكن وكيف تتنقل
بينها ، سيكون من الصعب على
المدينة التقاط أه تعلم سيرجي
شويغو الدفاعات  يقول الوزير الإلكتروني من ثلاثة إلى أربعة أيام
للقبض على كل من العقيد
ليتون وأعتقد أن هذا ضرب من الخيال حقًا
كانت هناك سلسلة من
الوفيات الغامضة لحكم القلة في الخارج في وقت لاحق
سيرجي بروتوسينا وجدت زوجته وابنته
ميتين في منزلهم في إسبانيا.
احتمال وقوع جريمة قتل
وانتحار يأتي بعد العثور على رئيس غاز روسي آخر
ميتًا في تجربتي في تغطية
روسيا عندما يسقط الصحفيون على سبيل المثال
من الشرفات ،
يتم تسميم قادة المعارضة أو
أشياء مثل هذه أه ليس بالصدفة
عندما ترى هذه الوفيات ،
ما رأيك
أنت تعلم أنه من السهل على أولئك منا
في الغرب أن يقولوا نوعًا ما جيدًا ، فربما
تكون هذه نظريات مؤامرة كبيرة ،
فربما مات هؤلاء الأشخاص للتو وفيات طبيعية ،
لكن المشكلة هي أنه
كلما تحدثت ضد شخص ما
ضد الحكومة الروسية سواء
كان حكم القلة  أو ما إذا كان
شخص ما داخل روسيا مثل
البحرية أو ما إذا كان أي من
الناس هم من الروس  لقد قتلوا أو
حاولوا القتل خارج روسيا ،
بدأت في رؤية هذا النمط من الحكومة الروسية التي
تلاحق منتقديها بغض النظر عما إذا كانوا داخل روسيا أم لا ، مما يجعل الأمر أسهل أو حتى خارج روسيا لا يمكننا أن ننسى سيرجي سكريبال  قبل عامين ، من
كان يعيش في بريطانيا العظمى في ذلك
الوقت ، وكنت تعرف موضوع
محاولة اغتيال ، لذا فإن هؤلاء
القلة في مواقف صعبة للغاية
إذا كانوا خارج روسيا ،
فهم غير مرتاحين لما يحدث.
لهم اقتصاديًا
وبدأوا في التحدث علنًا ضد
روسيا ولكن بعد ذلك تبدأ هذه الأشياء في
الحدوث والتي تخدم قضية بوتين
وهي وضع حد لهذه الأنواع من
الأشخاص ، حيث توفي حوالي 10 أشخاص اختناقًا
بمفردهم ، وكان أصغر طفل محتجز في الطابق السفلي
يبلغ من العمر ثلاثة أشهر بينما  أكبرهم سنًا
كان عمره 93 عامًا ولمدة تزيد عن
ثلاثة أسابيع ، مُنعوا من
مغادرة ذلك المكان 24 7.
حتى من الذهاب إلى الحمام وعندما
طلب أحدهم الخروج إلى g  وبعض
الملابس
للأطفال طالب المحتلون أن ينشدوا
النشيد الوطني الروسي ، وهكذا
استمتع الجنود الروس ،
وهذا هو نوع الإفلات من العقاب الذي شعروا به.